hallo mein name ist nikon herzlich
willkommen wie heute zahlen wie die idee
schon alte kulisse wieder ich den nicht
jeder an meinem kinderzimmer sondern bin
bei mir zu hause und leute die meinen
kanal schon ein bisschen länger
abonniert haben wissen ja dass dienstags
eigentlich minecraft kommen soll ich
fange jetzt mal von vorne an und zwar
hatte ich heute uni bis halb sechs und
hat danach in meinen ganzen taschen
ausgeräumt bin jetzt hier gerade ein pc
gegangen und wollte mich mit freunden
treffen gedacht okay minecraft anteil
aufzunehmen muss man ja auch nicht viel
dran schneiden kann ich jetzt schnell
zwischendurch mal reinschieben in meinen
zeitplan hab dann halt zum minecraft
geöffnet und hab dann halt gesehen okay
bin mit konkreter angemeldet klickt dann
so oft play in diesem fenster kommt da
dann einfach so jo das geht in die nähe
ich die planung mal deinen usernamen
einig so wieder ein gegeben dann wieder
so ausgeht nicht dann wollte ich mich
halt neu anmelden inhalt in dieses
fenster gekommen wo man emailadresse
username und dann das passwort dazu ein
geben muss und als ich das dann gemacht
habe mit meinen daten kamen dieses hier
soll über die user dem ipad wird ist
inkorrekt please try again i try before
i get post j link eigentlich ist das
mein richtiger usernamen richtiges
passwort gewesen aber ich habe mir davon
erstmal nichts sagen lassen hab dann
halt noch andere passwörter probierten
anstatt dort dann halt von crafter
einzugehen habe ich dann auch die email
adresse eingeben mit der ich das konto
verknüpft habe und es hat alles nicht
geklappt und ich habe halt wirklich
irgendwie 78 verschiedene passwörter die
ich mittlerweile auf allen webseiten
verwenden weil es einfach sicherer ist
also ich hab jetzt kein passwort fetisch
oder höher und keine zeit irgendwie
geklappt und dann habe ich halt gedacht
okay wenn es jetzt nicht klappt klicke
ich mal auf dem
passwort vergessen haben dort meine e
mail adresse eingegeben und ihr wisst ja
ich hatte schon mal probleme damit dass
meinen account gehackt wurde und jemand
anderes den irgendwie hatte den namen
und das haben wir auch alles hingekriegt
und das hat er jetzt auch drei vier fünf
monate perfekt geklappt mit minecraft
mit dem o'young support das waren echt
alles ultra coole leute und die haben
halt auch hingekriegt dass ich mein
account zurückbekommen habe nur habe ich
dann halt um beim thema zu bleiben ich
habe auch der passwort vergessen
webseite von mojang dann meine e mail
adresse eingegeben und war jetzt schon
locker irgendwie eine halbe stunde am
warten ob die mail von denen und die kam
halt noch immer nicht an
also ich weiß nicht ob der supporter
einfach nicht der allerschnellste ist
oder ob jetzt irgendwie mir auch noch
die e mailadresse geklaut wurde ein paar
sekunden später das ist nicht wahr genau
vor zwei minuten kriege ich diese
scheiße mail von maulbronn gegen haye
lotteries and imaging account festwirt
click & the following link genau jetzt
ich habe ungelogen diese scheiße
abgeschickt von einer halben stunde und
bin dann einfach mal so war ich die
ganze zeit gewartet habt ich meine mails
auch gegangen und hab dann so eine mail
gefunden ich lese ich die mal ganz kurz
vorher luca ich habe gesehen dass du auf
dem server minecraft eu hat jemand mit
deinem namen rumgelaufen ist als ich das
den leuten dort gesagt haben meinten sie
es bist du der echte das war ich aber
nicht und da dachte ich jetzt halt
gerade so okay das ist der beweis dafür
dass sich wirklich wieder gehackt wurde
und ich konnte mein passwort wieder
nicht eingeben
gerade aber jetzt anscheinend haben ja
gerade hier diese mail von mojang an und
ich probiere es jetzt mal eben kurz weg
in slate wird gerade mein neues passwort
eingegeben ist satte 37 zeichen lang und
jetzt kriege ich einfach mal auf reset
password soll chrome das speichern
nachmittags export has been set okay ich
jetzt mal ganz kurz um minecraft ob das
geklappt hat emailadresse und passwort
eingegeben ich klicke jetzt auf login
ich bin ein blog mit meinem account und
wenn ich jetzt auf play drücken steht
den downloading und es öffnet sich alles
wieder gut
kaum zurück ich würde jetzt unglaublich
gern noch 20 minuten eigenschaft
gameplay dranhängen wie gesagt schon
relativ spät ich treffe mich nach halbe
mit einem kumpel was essen zu gehen und
danach mit anderen komplett auszuziehen
weil wie gesagt wir wieder im schnitt
leben drin und es muss bereits aus nutzt
das habe ich nur noch ein jahr ich hoffe
ihr versteht das bei der lieben freunde
deswegen bin ich einfach sagen ich laden
morgen dieses mannschaft video hoch und
vielleicht noch ein zweites video aber
auf jeden fall kommen morgen wieder
minecraft gameplay ich dachte halt nur
sich auf dieses video hier angefangen
die meldung nicht bekommen die mail kam
jetzt wirklich vor 6 minuten also mojang
ihr seid einfach zu langsam ich dachte
schon wieder ich wurde gehackt also
fehlalarm wenn euch das video trotzdem
gefallen hat würde ich mich immer live
freuen morgen kommen minecraft und das
ist heute nicht mehr kommt ist einfach
weil ich keine zeit gehabt und ich habe
gedacht die ballade ich jetzt das hier
hoch um zu zeigen dass bei mir ab geht
als gar nichts hochzuladen ich hoffe ihr
versteht das ja